This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
也就是iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, it's Gemma. And I have something really special to share with you. I'm hosting my first ever virtual live video podcast, not a pre-recorded. episode, not a highlight reel, but a real time face-to-face moment where we get to connect, laugh and kind of just reflect together no matter where you are in the world. Plus, I'm hosting a VIP after party for my inner circle where I will be answering your questions and getting to talk to you guys even more.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。嘿，我是杰玛。我有一些非常特别的事情要与大家分享。我将主持我的第一个虚拟现场视频播客，不是预先录制的单集，不是精彩片段集锦，而是一个实时的面对面时刻，无论你身处世界何地，我们都可以建立联系、欢笑并进行一些共同的反思。此外，我还为我的核心圈子主持了一个VIP派对，我将在那里回答你们的问题，并与你们进行更多的交流。
It's happening August 12th at 7pm Pacific Time or August 13th at 12pm if you live in my hometown of Sydney. You can grab your ticket now at pave.live. I cannot wait to see you there. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course,
活动将于太平洋时间8月12日晚上7点举行，如果你住在我的家乡悉尼，则是8月13日中午12点。你现在就可以在pave.live上抢票。我迫不及待地想在那里见到大家。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，当然，我们
break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, to just jump straight to the chase, we are talking about perhaps one of the most defining parts of our 20s, the overwhelming uncertainty of just being in this decade. If this decade had one word to describe it, one theme to trump them all, it would be uncertainty. We are lost in this very weird haze of not really knowing who we are, not really knowing what the future holds, what's going to happen with our jobs, with our friends,
剖析你二十多岁的心理。今天，直奔主题，我们正在讨论二十多岁中最具定义性的部分之一，即仅仅处于这个十年中的那种压倒性的不确定性。如果这个十年可以用一个词来形容，一个胜过所有其他主题的主题，那就是不确定性。我们迷失在这个非常奇怪的迷雾中，不真正知道我们是谁，不真正知道未来会怎样，我们的工作、我们的朋友会发生什么，
with our finances, with our love lives. And even once you think you have some part of it figured out, another part of your life suddenly crumbles. And you're kind of just left feeling as lost as you were before. So I got this damn from a listener the other day that I wanted to share, which really inspired me to talk about this. Because going back through the archives, I realized we have never sat down. done a full episode dedicated to this feeling, despite it being, I would say, universal. This is what her DM said. Hi, Gemma, I'm in my 20s, like I'm sure most of your listeners are, so there must be others who relate to this feeling. My dilemma is that everyone tells me to just try something,
我们的财务状况、我们的爱情生活。而且，即使你认为你已经弄清楚了某一部分，你生活的另一部分也会突然崩溃。然后你基本上只会感到和以前一样迷失。所以前几天我从一位听友那里收到了这封私信，我想分享一下，这真的启发了我来谈论这个话题。因为回顾过往的资料，我意识到我们从来没有坐下来做过一整期专门探讨这种感觉的节目，尽管可以说这是普遍存在的。这是她的私信内容。嗨，杰玛，我二十多岁，就像我相信你大多数听友一样，所以肯定还有其他人对这种感觉感同身受。我的困境是，每个人都告诉我只管去尝试，
and that it doesn't matter what path I'm taking in my 20s as long as I'm moving forward. What really paralyzes me, though, is not knowing whether the path I choose to take will make me happy or at least happier than any other path. When I visualize my future, it just feels like a big, ominous gray cloud and I can't help but feel like if I just knew one part of the story, I could decide once and for all what direction to take. How do I deal with my fear of uncertainty? It's the biggest thing holding me back. I just knew like instantly upon reading this how many of us, and I can include myself in this group, can relate to that feeling. The feeling that our futures are not necessarily exciting, but actually really scary and really ominous. And a lot of that fear of the
并且在二十多岁时走哪条路并不重要，只要我在前进。然而，真正让我瘫痪的是，我不知道我选择的路是否会让我快乐，或者至少比任何其他路都更快乐。当我展望我的未来时，它感觉就像是一朵巨大而阴险的乌云，我不禁觉得，如果我能知道故事的一部分，我就可以一劳永逸地决定往哪个方向走了。我该如何应对我对不确定性的恐惧？这是阻碍我前进的最大因素。我几乎在阅读这封信的瞬间就知道，我们中有多少人，我也把自己包括在这个群体中，能够体会到那种感觉。那种我们的未来不一定令人兴奋，但实际上真的很可怕、很不祥的感觉。而这种对未知的大部分恐惧，确实助长了犹豫不决，也助长了不做在我们人生这个阶段做出决定所重要的决定，这当然又助长了后来的不满意。但我想，当你明白为什么我们一开始会感到如此不确定，为什么转身离开未知是人类的本性，但同时也明白我们如何能够转变对不确定性的感觉，
unknown really fuels indecision and it fuels not making decisions that are important to make at this stage in our life, which of course fuels later to satisfaction. But I think when you understand why we feel such uncertainty to begin with, why it is human nature to turn away from the unknown, but also how we can shift our feelings about uncertainty. so that it feels less scary, that is when this sensation has less control of you. You know, you're no longer fighting and losing battle against it. Uncertainty can become perhaps your sign that you're going in the right direction. It can be a sign of growth.
使其不那么可怕时，这种感觉对你的控制力就会减弱。你知道，你不再与它进行徒劳的抗争。不确定性可能会成为你走向正确方向的某种信号。它可能是成长的标志。
It can be a sign that you are trying new things and you're expanding as a person. So you welcome it. You welcome the sensation rather than running away from it. If that sounds kind of implausible and out of reach, let me explain how exactly we can get to that point. If you want to get to that place, we're going to have to make uncertainty feel like an asset. And we need to have a better strategy for coping with this feeling. And so that is exactly what we are going to talk about today, how we can celebrate rather than fear the unknown, how we can integrate this feeling into our life plan, see it as a sign, but also,
它可能是你正在尝试新事物、作为一个人正在拓展的标志。所以你欢迎它。你欢迎这种感觉，而不是逃离它。如果这听起来有点难以置信、遥不可及，让我来解释一下我们究竟如何才能达到那种状态。如果你想达到那种境界，我们需要让不确定性感觉像是一种资产。我们需要有更好的策略来应对这种感觉。所以这正是我们今天要讨论的内容，我们如何庆祝而不是害怕未知，我们如何将这种感觉融入我们的人生规划中，将其视为一个信号，但同时也是，
some of the origins of why we feel this way, not just in our 20s, but as a species. All of that and more and so much psychology, so stay with us. My fear of uncertainty, I think, definitely shifted when I realized that uncertainty is the opposite of boredom and predictability. If I knew exactly how my life was going to turn out, if I knew what was around every single corner, the name of every single friend I would meet, my entire resume until the time I retire. Yes, I would feel less uncertain. But what would the point of being alive even be? I think the newness of life, the experiences, the surprises, they are really what makes this whole thing worthwhile in a sense. You can't have surprises. You can't have unexpected
我们为什么会有这种感觉的一些根源，不仅是在二十多岁时，而且作为物种而言。所有这些以及更多内容和丰富的心理学知识，请继续收听我们的节目。我认为，当我意识到不确定性是无聊和可预测性的对立面时，我对不确定性的恐惧绝对发生了转变。如果我知道我的人生将如何发展，如果我知道每一个转角后面是什么，我将遇到的每一个朋友的名字，我退休前的整份简历。是的，我会感到不那么不确定。但活着还有什么意义呢？我认为生活的新鲜感、经历、惊喜，它们才是在某种意义上让这一切变得值得的真正原因。你不可能有惊喜。你不可能有意料之外的
joy. You can't learn. You can't have excitement and anticipation without uncertainty. It is a core ingredient in so many otherwise really amazing and pleasurable experiences. And that's what I'm personally learning to appreciate and focus on when I do have those very natural moments of being paralyzed by all that I don't know yet. I'm kind of jumping the gun here. Yes, uncertainty may have its upsides. We definitely can think about it differently. But why do we even experience it to begin with? And what makes it so freaking uncomfortable? That's really what we have to nail down first. Like I said in the beginning, uncertainty in our 20s are basically two peas in a pod for a variety of reasons.
喜悦。你无法学习。没有不确定性，你就无法拥有兴奋和期待。它是许多原本非常美妙和令人愉悦的体验中的核心成分。这就是我个人正在学会欣赏和关注的地方，当我确实遇到那些因未知而感到瘫痪的非常自然的时刻时。我有点操之过急了。是的，不确定性可能有其积极的一面。我们绝对可以对它有不同的看法。但我们为什么会经历它呢？是什么让它如此令人极度不舒服？这确实是我们首先要确定的。正如我在开始时所说，二十多岁的不确定性基本上是一拍即合的两个方面，原因多种多样。
Firstly, I want you to give yourself some grace. You are doing everything for the first time ever, basically. You are basically an adult toddler or an adult child who, yes, can read, hopefully and can write and is hopefully potty trained and all those things. But you are now experiencing the next level of situation. the next level of learning experiences that are emotionally complex and not straightforward. And as you're experiencing that, you also are without the same safety net that you relied upon when you were younger.
首先，我希望你对自己宽容一点。你基本上是生平第一次在做所有事情。你基本上是一个成年幼儿或成年儿童，是的，能够阅读，希望还能写作，希望还能如厕训练以及所有这些事情。但你现在正在经历更高层次的情境。更高层次的学习经历，它们在情感上很复杂，并不直观。在经历这些的同时，你也没有了年轻时依赖的安全网。
And you're without the reassurance and the security of teachers and parents and a school system and a societal system that hopefully isn't going to let you fall through the cracks. You're on your own. An uncertainty, therefore, feels a lot more, a lot. because you feel like you're the one who is going to hold the burden, experience the full burden of any poor decision or any poor outcome you made. It's all on you at this point. Another element of this is that because you are an adult toddler, you haven't had enough life experience yet to know that things will eventually work out for you, even if they don't
你没有了老师、学校系统和社会系统的安慰和安全感，希望这个社会系统不会让你从缝隙中掉落。你只能靠自己。因此，不确定性感觉更加重大，更加……因为你觉得你是那个要承担负担、承担任何糟糕决定或糟糕结果的全部负担的人。在这个阶段，一切都取决于你。这其中的另一个因素是，因为你是一个成年幼儿，你还没有足够的生活经验来知道事情最终会为你解决，即使它们没有
the first time, even if they are not working out right now. People in their 40s, their 50 years and later, they know that the breakup isn't the end of the world because they've experienced them and survived before. They know making a major mistake or losing a friend or losing a job isn't the end of the world because they have evidence from previous life experience to tell them that. But you, you don't have those same data points. You don't have that same catalog of examples that tell you everything is going to be okay. Uncertainty for you and uncertainty for a lot of us in our 20s doesn't have a conclusion the way that it has for people who are older. Then, of course, just to add even more fuel to the fire, there's the fact that you're kind of living
第一次，即使它们现在没有奏效。四十多岁、五十多岁及以后的人知道分手并不是世界末日，因为他们经历过并生存下来了。他们知道犯重大错误、失去朋友或失去工作并不是世界末日，因为他们有以前生活经验的证据来告诉他们这一点。但是你，你没有那些相同的数据点。你没有那种充满例子的目录来告诉你一切都会好起来的。对于你，以及对于我们许多二十多岁的人来说，不确定性的结局不像年长的人那样有一个结论。然后，当然，为了火上浇油，还有这样一个事实，即你有点生活在
between milestones. And this decade is definitely one of perpetual transition. You know, you're no longer a teenager, but, you know, you don't really feel like an adult yet. You're not at that financial level. You're not settled in a career. You're not settled in a relationship. the way that you expect adults to be. What are you really?
里程碑之间。这个十年绝对是一个持续过渡的时期。你知道，你不再是一个青少年，但是，你知道，你还真的不觉得自己是个成年人。你没有达到那个财务水平。你没有在一个职业中安定下来。你没有在一段关系中安定下来。就像你期望成年人那样。你到底是什么？
It's what psychologists call a liminal space, the in-between. And liminal emotional spaces are, by nature, by definition, disorientating, because they don't come with a clear script. And, of course, there's no accurate way, and there's no one who's going to be able to tell you, like, okay, you're doing, you're doing well, you're doing fine. You are being, you are successful. Earlier in life, this is something I talk to people about all the time. Earlier in life,
这就是心理学家所说的边缘空间，即中间地带。而边缘的情感空间，就其本质和定义而言，是令人迷失方向的，因为它们没有附带清晰的剧本。而且，当然，没有准确的方法，也没有人能告诉你，比如，好吧，你做得很好，你做得很好。你正在变得，你很成功。在人生的早期，这是我经常和人们谈论的事情。在人生的早期，
your entire days, weeks, months are set up in a structure that will tell you if you are doing well. There are clear benchmarks for life performance, things like grades, things like passing to the next year level, things like a whole cohort of people in the same situation at the same time and the same age as you, with whom you can mark your progress against. And they're probably all in the same environment, like at school. You don't have that anymore. You don't have that same framework to look around and think, okay, I'm doing okay or I'm not doing okay.
你的整天、整周、整月都是在一个结构中建立的，这个结构会告诉你你是否做得很好。生活表现有明确的基准，比如成绩，比如升入下一个年级，比如一大群处于相同环境、同时代、与你同龄的人，你可以用他们来对照你的进度。而且他们可能都在同一个环境中，比如在学校里。你不再有那个了。你不再有那种框架可以环顾四周，心想，好吧，我做得很好，或者我做得不好。
And these are the areas I can improve, or these are the areas that I'm excelling. You don't have that anymore. And it might seem really arbitrary, but those social structures and those environmental structures, and that context actually provides a great deal of, in a great sense of calm and stability. So you have, during this decade, almost suddenly lost a lot of what previously allowed to just stay grounded. Security, structure, direction.
这些是我可以改进的领域，或者这些是我表现出色的领域。你不再有那个了。这可能看起来很武断，但那些社会结构、环境结构以及这种背景实际上提供了很大程度的、极大的平静感和稳定性。所以在这个十年里，你几乎突然失去了以前允许你保持脚踏实地的很多东西。安全感、结构、方向。
And of course, finally, what may feel like a curse, but certainly isn't, is the fact that as a generation, we have more choices than ever. We really do. And it's a beautiful thing, and everyone tells us we're very privileged. We also know that that creates a real paradox of choice that can be quite stifling. You know, it is amazing that when we're in our 20s, like 80% of the doors are open to us. Definitely there are some things that we probably can't do anymore. You know, unfortunately, you're probably not going to become an Olympic gymnast if you haven't been training since you were a trial. But in general, you know, you're at the start line of pretty much everything else. All the doors are open. Do you know how utterly terrifying that actually is?
当然，最后，可能感觉像个诅咒但绝对不是诅咒的事实是，作为一个代际群体，我们拥有比以往更多的选择。确实如此。这是一件美好的事情，每个人都告诉我们我们非常特权。我们也知道，这确实会产生一种真正的选择悖论，可能会让人感到相当压抑。你知道，令人惊奇的是，当我们二十多岁时，大约80%的大门向我们敞开。当然，有些事情我们可能再也做不到了。不幸的是，如果你从小没有接受过训练，你可能不会成为一名奥运体操运动员。但总的来说，你知道，你几乎在所有其他事情的起跑线上。所有的大门都敞开着。你知道这实际上有多么绝对可怕吗？
you probably do it because you're experiencing it, but it certainly does feel like with each decision you make, the more doors you seem to close with no certainty around whether you might actually want to go back through that door later, and no certainty around what might happen next. Closing those doors seems a lot more scary than it does fulfilling. So you do nothing. You're paralyzed by choice and the endless pro-cons list that we know. as decision paralysis. That's really the 20-something explanation for uncertainty. There's also a more human explanation as to why uncertainty in any capacity, not just when it comes to the big ticket items of our 20s, is so uncomfortable for us as a species. To firstly really state the obvious,
你可能知道，因为你正在经历它，但它确实让人觉得，你做出的每一个决定，似乎都会关闭更多的大门，而且对于你以后是否还想重新走过那扇门没有任何确定性，对于接下来会发生什么也没有任何确定性。关闭那些大门似乎比实现它们要可怕得多。所以你什么也不做。你被选择和我们所知道的无休止的利弊清单所瘫痪，这就是所谓的决策瘫痪。这确实是对二十多岁不确定性的解释。对于为什么不确定性在任何情况下，不仅在我们二十多岁的重大事项上，对我们作为一个物种来说如此不舒服，还有一个更具人性的解释。首先非常显而易见的是，
our brains, they are wired to seek out stability and clarity because when something is known and familiar, there are, of course, less opportunities for danger and threats. Now, the part of our brain that controls this primal urge, there's two specific regions, actually. It's the prefrontal cortex, so right up here at the front, and the limbic system, which is really deep inside our brain. It's part of what we call the old brain. A series of studies done in the early 2000s basically found that when we are exposed to ambiguous things like an ambiguous image or ambiguous, scenery, the limbic system, particularly the amygdala, light up. Even when these participants were in a laboratory setting, where there is no immediate danger, your brain is always going to respond
我们的大脑天生就是为了寻求稳定和清晰而连线的，因为当某事是已知和熟悉的时，危险和威胁的机会当然会更少。现在，控制这种原始冲动的大脑部分其实有两个特定区域。一个是前额叶皮层，就在这里的正前方，另一个是边缘系统，它位于我们大脑的深处。它是我们称之为旧大脑的一部分。2000年代初进行的一系列研究基本上发现，当我们暴露于模糊的事物（如模糊的图像或模糊的风景）时，边缘系统，尤其是杏仁核，会被点亮。即使这些参与者处于实验室环境中，那里没有直接的危险，你的大脑总是会对它不理解的事物（如未来的未知数）做出过度谨慎和过分热情的反应。
overcautiously and overzealously to something it doesn't understand, such as the unknowns of the future. But that feeling is also something that we can't suppress. It's automatic. And for good reason, You know, we want that part of us that assesses danger to not be reliant on our judgment and to be able to act quick. And, you know, the reason that we have such an aversion to uncertainty is primarily rooted in the fact that we needed to in order to survive. When you face an unknown, you know, your brain will immediately seek out as much information as it can, real or imagined to feel the gaps. Our brain is wired to do this. You might know this by another term, which is catastrophizing. Your brain is trying to figure out what's every possible thing that's going to happen here.
但这种感觉也是我们无法抑制的。它是自动的。而且有充分的理由，你知道，我们希望大脑中评估危险的那部分不依赖于我们的判断，并且能够快速行动。而且，你知道，我们对不确定性有如此强烈的厌恶，主要是植根于这样一个事实：为了生存，我们需要它。当你面对未知时，你知道，你的大脑会立即寻找尽可能多的信息，无论是真实的还是想象的，来填补空白。我们的大脑天生就会这样做。你可能通过另一个术语知道这一点，那就是灾难化。你的大脑正试图弄清楚这里可能发生的所有事情是什么。
It's going to simulate outcomes. It's going to generate predictions. The problem is it actually has no idea what's going to happen. So it serves up all these situations, some of them completely impossible, some of them may be more likely. We can't always discern or tell the difference between what is more likely and what is less likely. We are just receiving information from this very old, ancient part of our brain. And we're experiencing it as it comes. We're experiencing all the fear as it comes without being able to interrupt that and say,
它将模拟结果。它将产生预测。问题是它实际上根本不知道会发生什么。所以它呈现出所有这些情况，有些完全不可能，有些可能更有可能。我们并不总是能够辨别或区分什么更有可能，什么更不可能。我们只是从我们大脑中这个非常古老的部分接收信息。随着它的到来，我们体验着它。随着恐惧的到来，我们体验着所有的恐惧，却无法打断它并说，
wait, how do I, why do I think this? How do I know this is going to happen? Oh, wait, I actually don't. So this brings me to a next point. A lot of our anxiety and our fears don't actually emerge from necessarily something having gone wrong in actuality. But from the question of what if, what if this happens? What if this even worse thing happens? What if the worst thing happens?
等等，我怎么会，我为什么会这么想？我怎么知道这会发生？哦，等等，我其实并不知道。所以这就引出了我的下一个点。我们的许多焦虑和恐惧其实并不一定源于实际出错的事情，而是源于“如果……会怎样”这个问题，如果发生这种情况会怎样？如果发生更糟糕的事情会怎样？如果最糟糕的事情发生了会怎样？
This is because our brain will stay in this loop of providing us with potential outcomes until it has some kind of resolution or closure. It doesn't want to switch off the alarm system until the reason for the alarm has been given meaning or it's identified what the problem was. And like I said, in the past that was useful, now it's just plain old annoying. It's annoying. And your uncertainty is meant to feel that way. It's meant to feel annoying and awful and frustrating because, again, it wants to keep you alert.
这是因为我们的大脑将停留在这种为我们提供潜在结果的循环中，直到它有某种决议或闭环。在赋予警报原因以意义或识别出问题所在之前，它不想关闭警报系统。就像我说的，过去这很有用，现在它只是老掉牙的烦人。这很烦人。你的不确定性就是为了让人有这种感觉。它本意就应该是烦人的、糟糕的和令人沮丧的，因为同样，它想让你保持警觉。
It wants to grab your attention. Like a big shiny billboard or a big red stop sign, it wants you to be looking straight at it. It wants you to be directing. It's focused onto the thing you don't understand and that you're unsure about so that you can provide it. with a sense of closure. The thing is, if you give your anxiety and your fear of the unknown an answer, if you give yourself a reason for the uncertainty, more specifically you give it a purpose, it will actually go away. We are going to discuss that more in a second, so just bear with me. But it's also important as well before we move on to understand that how you experience uncertainty
它想吸引你的注意力。就像一个巨大的闪亮广告牌或一个巨大的红色停止标志，它希望你直视它。它希望你把注意力集中在你所不理解和不确定的一件事情上，以便你能为它提供一种闭环感。问题是，如果你给你的焦虑和对未知的恐惧一个答案，如果你为不确定性给自己一个理由，更具体地说，你给它一个目的，它实际上就会消失。我们待会儿会更多地讨论这一点，所以请耐心听我讲。但在我们继续之前，同样重要的是要了解，你如何在二十多岁时体验不确定性
in your 20s is not the same as how everyone else is going to experience this feeling. So you can't beat yourself up if you feel like you are struggling with it more than others. Psychologists in the early 90s, they identified what they called an intolerance for uncertainty spectrum. Basically, they found that where you sit in terms of your tolerance or intolerance for uncertainty will determine how much information you think you need before you make a decision. They discovered this spectrum almost by accident. They were actually trying to determine what personality traits caused anxiety and in that research what they kept realizing that was that a number of their participants all reported the same experience, this sense that they weren't necessarily
与其他人体验这种感觉的方式并不完全相同。所以如果你觉得你比其他人更难应付，你也不用过分自责。90年代初的心理学家确定了他们所谓的不确定性不耐受光谱。基本上，他们发现你在不确定性容忍度或不确定性不耐受光谱上的位置决定了你在做决定之前认为自己需要多少信息。他们几乎是偶然发现这个光谱的。他们实际上是想确定哪些人格特质会导致焦虑，而在那项研究中，他们不断意识到的是，许多参与者都报告了相同的经历，即这种感觉，即他们不一定
scared about what was going to happen. They just really wanted to know what was going to happen. And these same people were the ones who would read ahead in books, even if they were excited by the plotline. They would read spoilers in the papers of movies that they were really eager to see, even though they knew it was going to kind of ruin the enjoyment. They would also at times make more impulsive decisions in their relationships when they felt something was fading or feeling off, not because they necessarily wanted the relationship to end, but because to them, and this kept coming up over and over again,
害怕会发生什么。他们只是真的很想知道会发生什么。同样这些人也是那些会在书中提前阅读的人，即使他们对情节很兴奋。他们会在他们非常渴望观看的电影报纸上阅读剧透，即使他们知道这会毁掉观赏乐趣。有时他们还会在人感觉正在消退或不对劲时，在恋爱关系中做出更冲动的决定，不是因为他们一定希望这段关系结束，而是因为对他们来说，这不断地反复出现，
a known bad outcome was better than an unknown good outcome. These same individuals were also, surprise, surprise, more likely to have a diagnosis of generalized anxiety. disorder. Most people in society and in our world will score in the middle of this spectrum for an intolerance for uncertainty. But people who score higher, probably like you and I, tend to spend a lot more time ruminating on the future than being in the present moment. And they just can't help it. Someone with a high intolerance for uncertainty, they might make lists repeatedly. They plan out conversations in their head. They look at food menus well before they're
一个已知的糟糕结果比一个未知的良好结果要好。这些人也，不出所料，更有可能被诊断为广泛性焦虑障碍。社会和世界上的大多数人在不确定性不耐受光谱上得分居中。但得分较高的人，可能就像你和我，往往花更多的时间反刍未来，而不是活在当下。他们就是忍不住。一个具有高度不确定性不耐受的人，他们可能会反复列清单。他们在脑海中规划对话。他们在去餐馆之前很久就查看菜单，只是为了确保那里有他们喜欢的东西，并且知道他们要点什么。他们三番五次地核对驾驶路线。他们做所有这些事情。基本上是为了平息这种感觉：如果我不知道，那么就会出问题。我面前的这片乌云，它只能是危险的。如果是这样的话，你的二十多岁是很自然的。
going to a restaurant just to make sure that they know that there's something they're going to like and they know what they're going to order. They triple check driving routes. They do all these things. Basically to calm this sense that if I don't know, well, then something's going to go wrong. This cloud ahead of me, it can only be dangerous. If this is you, your 20s are natural. and I'm sorry to say it, they are going to feel a lot more stressful. And they're going to feel harder than someone who can naturally go with the flow because you are constantly being bombarded with unknowns and it's not you. It's this decade.
我很遗憾这么说，但你会觉得压力大得多。而且它会比那些能够自然随波逐流的人感觉更难，因为你不断受到未知事物的轰炸，这不是你的问题。是这个十年。我向你保证，我马上会给你带来一些好消息和解决方案，但我确实想谈谈如果我们让不确定性迫使我们陷入死角或迫使我们采取不行动会发生什么。因为不确定性是如此令人不舒服，它可能是一个非常强大的非适应性动机，即激励我们做实际上违背我们利益的事情的东西。了解这一点真的很重要。所以当我们暂停并选择是采取行动还是不采取行动时，
I promise you I'm going to give you some good news and some solutions in just a second, but I do want to talk about what can happen if we let uncertainty force us into a corner or force us into a place of an action. Because uncertainty is so uncomfortable, it can be a very powerful maladaptive motivator, i.e. something that motivates us to do things that are actually against our interest. And it's really important that we are aware of that. So that when we pause and are choosing whether to act, whether not to act,
我们可以仔细检查这是否符合我们的最佳利益，还是仅仅因为我们害怕一个并不比任何其他结果更有可能或更不可能的结果。这在我们的二十多岁中表现出来的形式可能是一个很长的清单，但我会保持简短，我不想吓唬你。我只想触及让这种感觉主宰你生活带来的两个主要后果。首先，你接受了你不配得到的，也接受了低于你能力和低于你实际努力成果的东西。这就像我之前说的，你更喜欢一个已知的糟糕结果，而不是一个未知的良好结果。
we can carefully examine whether this is in our best interest or just because we are scared of an outcome that is no more or less likely than any other outcome. The ways this shows up in our 20s could be a very long list. but I'm going to keep it brief and I want to scare you. I'm just going to touch on two of the big consequences of letting this feeling rule your life. Firstly, you accept what you don't deserve and also less than what you're capable of and less than what you've actually worked for. It's like what I said before, a known bad outcome over an unknown good outcome is what you prefer.
这看起来可能是这样的：接受第一份研究生录取通知书，因为你害怕拿不到另一份，即使你并不真的想要这份工作。接受第一个，我不知道，在Hinge上开始跟你聊天的人，因为你害怕没有人会跟你聊天，而且你害怕在一定年龄后单身意味着什么。你选择你看到的第一个公寓，你尝试的第一辆车。你一遍又一遍地去相同的地方，进行相同的旅行。因为一个不确定的结果，即使有可能是惊人的，你也不想
And how that might look like is accepting the first grad offer because you're scared of not getting another, even though you don't really want the job. Accepting the first person who, I don't know, starts talking to you on Hinge because you're scared that no one else will talk to you and you're scared of what it will mean to be single after a certain age. You choose the first apartment you see, the first car you try out. You go to the same places, on the same trips over and over again. Because an uncertain outcome, even if there is a chance that it could be amazing, you don't want
冒这个险。请记住，我对这没有任何评判。我自己也做过。所有这些基本上都是轶事。所有这些基本上都是我亲身经历的生活，因为我和你是在同一条船上的。在我们二十多岁时未能拥抱不确定性的第二个后果是，我们实际上根本不采取行动。我们不选择任何工作。我们不选择任何伴侣，因为如果它不是正确的那个怎么办？你知道，在第一种情况下，我们选择了第一样东西。在这种情况下，我们根本不选择任何东西。你可能不会感到惊讶，完美主义和对不确定性的恐惧实际上是，
to take that risk. Bear in mind, I have no judgment on this. I have done this myself. All of that is basically anecdotal. All of that is basically my lived experience because I am someone who is in the same boat with you. The second consequence of a failure to embrace uncertainty in our 20s is that we actually don't act at all. We don't choose any job. We don't choose any partner because what if it's not the right one? You know, in the first scenario, we chose the first thing. In this scenario, we don't choose anything at all. It probably won't surprise you that perfectionism and the fear of uncertainty are actually,
事实上，是姐妹。它们高度一致。事实上，我个人认为完美主义基本上只是换了个名字的对不确定性的恐惧。它就像这种感觉的一个子流派。完美主义经常伪装成野心、高标准或对自己的巨大期望，但在其背后通常只是恐惧。它只是一种对未知的恐惧，对失败可能带来的恐惧，对做出错误举动的恐惧。它实际上关心的较少是如何完美地做事，
in fact, sisters. They are incredibly aligned. In fact, I personally think that perfectionism is basically just the fear of uncertainty with a different name. It's like a subgenre of the feeling. Perfectionism often disguises itself as ambition or high standards or great expectations for yourself, but underneath it's usually just fear. It's just a fear of the unknown, the fear of what failure might bring, the fear of making the wrong move. It is actually less about doing things
而更多的是试图消除后悔的可能性。这就是为什么它是不确定性的近亲。它们都源于对不知道事情将如何发展的深深的不适感。在这种情况下，把完美主义想象成某种情感盔甲。如果我计划得足够多，如果我把决定推迟得足够久，如果我把所有事情都做得恰到好处，那么也许，也许我可以避免失望。但你真正做的只是试图跑赢不确定性。2022年的一项研究实际上观察了一群学生，以确定完美主义是否意味着人们在做决定时行动不那么迅速。他们要求这些学生完成一份问卷，该问卷基本上根据完美主义倾向对每个学生进行排名。所以
perfectly and more about trying to eliminate the possibility of regret. That's what makes it a close relative of uncertainty. They both come from a deep discomfort with not knowing how things will turn out. Think of perfectionism in this case as kind of like an emotional armor. If I just plan enough, if I delayed the decision long enough, if I do everything just right, then maybe, maybe I can avoid disappointment. But what you're really doing is just trying to outrun uncertainty. A 2022 study actually looked at a group of students to determine whether perfectionism meant people were less quick to act when it came to making a decision. They asked these students to complete a questionnaire, which would essentially rank each student based on perfectionist tendencies. So
从最高完美主义到最低完美主义。然后他们要求这些学生考虑一系列“你宁愿”的问题。所以你宁愿，我不知道，这个还是那个？你宁愿X还是Y？大约有，我想，50个，50种情况。他们测量了他们完成这一整套情况所花费的时间。排名前25%的完美主义者完成这项练习所花费的总时间与其余75%的学生相当。他们花了这么长时间，因为他们坐在那里考虑想要做出完美的抉择。问题是，机会并不总是等着我们做出决定。重大的决定并不总是让你推迟它们。
the most perfectionist down to the least perfectionist. And then they asked those students to consider a bunch of would you rather questions. So would you rather, I don't know, this or that? Would you rather X or Y? There was about, I think, 50 of them, 50 scenarios. And they measured how long it took them to complete these entire range of scenarios. The top 25% of perfectionist took the same amount of time combined to complete the exercise as the remaining 75% of students. They took so much longer because they were sat there considering wanting to make the perfect choice. The thing is, opportunities don't always wait for us to make up our minds. Big decisions aren't always going to let you delay them.
它们会找到下一个人，或者它们会消失。我们二十多岁很大的一部分是能够对那件感觉真的很可怕的事情说“好”。是的，我要尝试。是的，我不知道会发生什么。不管怎样，让我做吧。但是当你与所有的恐惧之王——对未知的恐惧作斗争时，这会对你来说难得多。最后，我来给你带好消息。这实际上是你可以改变的事情。这是许多人已经向自己证明他们能够克服的事情。所以我想精确地解释你如何做到这一点，包括你如果愿意的话在接下来的五分钟内实际上可以做的事情，它将使你能够更好地付诸行动来实现你的梦想，实现
They will find the next person or they will. disappear. A big part of our 20s is being able to say yes to that thing that feels really scary. Yes, I'm going to try. Yes, I don't know what's going to happen. Let me just do it anyways. But when you are battling the fear of all fears, the fear of the unknown, that's going to be a lot harder for you. Finally, I'm here to give you some good news. This is actually something you can change. And it's something that many people have proven to themselves that they are able to overcome. So I want to explain exactly how you can do this, including something you could literally do in the next five minutes if you wanted to that will allow you to better act on your dreams, on the
机会，实现我们二十多岁的渴望。所以在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。嘿，我是杰玛，我有一些非常特别的事情要与大家分享。我将主持我的第一个虚拟现场视频播客，不是预先录制的单集，不是精彩片段集锦，而是一个实时的面对面时刻，无论你身处世界何地，我们都可以建立联系、欢笑、反思，老实说，就是一起经历这一切。如果你曾经播放过《你的二十多岁心理学》或《Mantra》中的一集，并心想，我真希望我现在就能和杰玛谈谈这个。这就是你的机会。我们将深入探讨你二十多岁、三十多岁以及以后生活中的杂乱、美丽的混乱。
opportunities, on the desires of our 20s. So we're going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. Hey, it's Gemma, and I have something really. special to share. I'm hosting my first ever virtual live video podcast, not a pre-recorded episode, not a highlight reel, but a real time face-to-face moment where we get to connect, laugh, reflect, and honestly just kind of be in it together no matter where you are in the world. If you've ever hit play on an episode of the psychology of your 20s or mantra and thought, I really wish I could just talk to Gemma about this right now. This is your chance. We're diving into the messy, beautiful chaos of your 20s, your 30s of life and beyond.
是的，你可以和我在那里。这里有一个实时聊天室，这样我们可以实时交流。随后，我将举办一个私人的VIP派对，我们称之为我的核心圈子，我将在那里回答你们的问题，并进行更多的个人交流。活动将于太平洋时间8月12日晚上7点举行，如果你在悉尼或澳大利亚，则是8月13日中午12点。所以请在你的日历上做个记号，告诉你的朋友。现在就在 pave.live 上抢票。我迫不及待地想在那里见到你。
And yes, you get to be right there with me. There's a live chat so we can talk in real time. And afterwards, I'm hosting a private VIP party, my inner circle, we would call it, where I'll be answering your questions and getting even more personal. It's happening August 12th at 7pm Pacific Time or August 13th at 12pm if you're on Sydney or Australia. So mark your calendar, tell your friends. Grab your ticket now at pave. Live. I can't wait to see you there.
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的数。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立抗逆力的科学。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是会引起炎症的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更 healthier 的人。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。也就是iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
所以我开始看到一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果派（Apple Pies）或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客，由我这个主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域的十多年经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，莱恩·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐了，
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Pies. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现在地球上做一个好人很重要？
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们没有意识到自己已经拥有了那个东西。我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌，生活变成了胜负之争。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，为什么你们觉得在世期间做一个好人如此重要？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
是因为你害怕才做一个好人吗？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。确实如此。这也是两种不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我和Kear Gaines，我们将深入探讨疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标等真实话题
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be
暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律诉讼序幕，只为证明真相。你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能
able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。这还没结束，
or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends,
直到亚利桑那州伸张正义。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下姑娘。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《闺蜜》的新一季中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
天哪，这就是同一个人。一群女人发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓，
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, so we are back talking about uncertainty in our 20s. And luckily for us, we are actually not the first generation to feel this way,
我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。好了，我们回来聊聊二十岁时的不确定性。对我们来说幸运的是，实际上我们并不是第一代有这种感受的人，
nor will we be the last. And that's good news because it means that there are a lot of people who have come up with some really amazing approaches to this feeling that helped get them through this period of discomfort, which will hopefully help you as well. The biggest thing we can do for our uncertainty in our 20s, and I've been hinting at this for the entire episode, is to basically assign it a purpose. Because that satisfies our deeper desire for a reason, a meeting, and kind of just a sense of why. Why is this happening?
也不会是最后一代。这是个好消息，因为这意味着有很多人想出了一些非常棒的方法来应对这种感觉，帮助他们度过这段不适期，希望这也能对你有所帮助。我们能为二十岁的不确定性做的最重要的事情——我已经在整个节目中暗示这一点了——就是基本上给它赋予一个目的。因为这满足了我们内心深处对原因、意义以及某种“为什么”的需求。为什么会发生这种事？
The purpose you assign to your uncertainty, it could be that you see this as a learning opportunity. It could be that you view uncertainty as a learning opportunity. It could be that you view uncertainty as a rite of passage. It could be that uncertainty is a sign that you're opening yourself up to new things, which are scary. It could be a call to surrender and just to accept life as it is. It could be a real spiritual thing. It could be that uncertainty just makes for a really good story. And you value a good story and you can't have one without uncertainty. Whatever it is, whatever makes uncertainty feel, meaningful to you, hone in on that. Anytime you feel overwhelmed by the feeling, remind yourself, okay, but this has a purpose. This has a meaning. For me, I personally think of uncertainty as a sign that I'm about to really grow as a person and, for lack of a better word, I'm about to level up. Every time I have ever felt scared, lost, uncertain, it has always been the beginning of something just over the horizon that I haven't been able to see yet.
你赋予不确定性的目的，可以是把这看作一个学习的机会。你可以把不确定性视为一个学习的机会。你可以把不确定性视为一种成人礼。不确定性可能是一个信号，表明你正在向新事物敞开心扉，而这令人感到害怕。它可能是一个顺其自然的呼唤，只是接受现状。这可能是一种真正的精神层面的事情。不确定性也可能只是造就了一个非常好的故事。你珍视一个好故事，而没有不确定性就写不出好故事。无论是什么，只要能让不确定性对你来说变得有意义，就专注于此。每当你被这种感觉压倒时，提醒自己，好吧，但这有一个目的。这有一个意义。就我个人而言，我认为不确定性是我个人即将迎来真正成长的一个信号，用一个不太恰当的词来说，我即将“升级”。每当我感到害怕、迷失、不确定时，它总是预示着某种即将在地平线上出现、而我目前还看不到的新事物的开始。
Like it always signals to me that like something really big is about to come. That way now, now that I know that's its purpose, I actually almost get excited when I'm feeling that way. I feel like I get kind of giddy. I'm like ready to be surprised. And I really feel like I'm in preparation mode for whatever is about to happen next. The reason this worked is because when we assign a role to our uncertainty, this actually gives us a cognitive framework through which we can accept it, through which we can just let it exist and actually focus on what we need to focus on. We give the annoying voice a job. It's like when a toddler, I don't know if you've been around kids a lot, but when like a toddler or a child is being really annoying, so you tell them they have to
就像它总是向我发出信号，预示着有什么大事即将发生。这样一来，既然我知道了它的目的，每当我产生这种感觉时，我甚至几乎会感到兴奋。我感觉自己有点飘飘然，随时准备好迎接惊喜。我真的觉得自己进入了为接下来要发生的事情做准备的状态。之所以管用，是因为当我们给不确定性分配一个角色时，这实际上为我们提供了一个认知框架，通过这个框架我们可以接受它，通过这个框架我们可以让它存在，并真正专注于我们需要关注的事情。我们给那个烦人的声音安排了一项工作。就像当一个蹒跚学步的孩子——我不知道你是不是经常和孩子在一起，但当一个幼儿或小孩真的很烦人时，你会告诉他们，他们必须
rearrange all the pens or they have to divide up all their dolls or pick up something like rice, I don't know, you give them a job so you can get to work. You give the annoying voice somewhere, someone else to talk to or something else to do. The second way to really confront your uncertainty is also to look for stories of people who didn't have it all figured out or whom dealt with supreme uncertainty and came out the other side, rather than just looking for people who seem like a natural A to B success story. The natural success stories are all we seem to see these days. So you would think that most people who you admire have never struggled the way that you do and that you have.
把所有的笔重新排列，或者把他们所有的娃娃分门别类，或者捡起像大米之类的小东西，我不知道，你给他们找个活儿干，这样你就能专心工作了。你给那个烦人的声音找个地方、找另一个人去说，或者找别的事去做。直面不确定性的第二种方法，是去寻找那些并非一切都顺风顺水、或者经历过极大不确定性最终却走出困境的人的故事，而不是只去找那些看起来天然就从A顺利成功走到B的人。如今我们似乎只能看到那些天生成功的故事。所以你可能会认为，大多数你钦佩的人从来没有经历过像你这样的挣扎。
That's false. It's a huge lie. It's a big myth. When you start collecting these stories, you will find that almost every single person who has made something of themselves has an uncertainty story. Dochi, for example, that's one I've recently added to my list, The Woman of the Hour. She posted a YouTube video back in 2020, only like five years ago about how she got fired from her job. And in it she's like, tomorrow I'm just going to door knock at a bunch of studios and just see if they will give me an internship. She just won a Grammy.
这是假的。这是一个弥天大谎。这是一个巨大的神话。当你开始搜集这些故事时，你会发现几乎每一个有所成就的人都有一个关于不确定性的故事。比如多琪（Dochi），这是我最近添加到我清单里的一个，也就是《时辰之光》（The Woman of the Hour）的主演。她在2020年——也就是大约五年前——发布了一个YouTube视频，讲的是她是如何被解雇的。在视频里她说，明天我要去敲一堆工作室的门，看看他们能不能给我提供一个实习机会。而她刚刚赢得了格莱美奖。
Five years ago, she was completely unsure of where she was going to end up. And she ended up in the right place because she lent into it. The founder of Spanx, she's another one on my list. She used to sell fax machines like door to door. Now she runs a billion dollar industry. Stephen King, he's another one. His draft for his book, Carrie, which is now a cult classic, a favorite of so many. He literally threw that manuscript in the trash after it was rejected 30 times.
五年前，她完全不知道自己最终会走向何方。而她之所以走到了正确的地方，是因为她顺应了这种不确定性。Spanx（修身内衣品牌）的创始人，也是我名单上的另一位。她曾经挨家挨户推销传真机。现在她经营着一个价值数十亿美元的产业。斯蒂芬·金，他是又一个例子。他的小说《魔女嘉莉》的草稿——现在这是一部邪典经典，是许多人的最爱——在被拒绝了30次后，他 literalmente（字面意思）把手稿扔进了垃圾桶。
And that book is a cultural icon. I even think of my mom. My mom is the one that often comes to mind for me. you know, she was kicked out of university because she got such poorly bad grades. They basically expelled her. And then she took a year off to travel. She didn't really know what she wanted to do. She came back.
而那本书已经成了一个文化偶像。我甚至想到了我的妈妈。我妈妈经常是我脑海中最先浮现的例子。你知道，她因为成绩太差而被大学开除。他们基本上把她赶出了学校。然后她请了一年假去旅行。她其实不知道自己想做什么。她回来了。
She did something different. And she graduated with a top job. And now she's like this incredibly powerful, successful girl boss. All these people and you have something very important in common in their journey to success and to wherever they ended. up, there were moments when they had absolutely no idea what was next and they just had to bet on themselves and they just had to trust that they were capable. And once you start searching for these stories, you will see them everywhere. You will see them constantly until one day you'll have your own version of this story, your own version of how you overcame uncertainty, how in
她做了不同的事。最终以优异的成绩毕业，找到了一份顶尖的工作。现在她是一个令人难以置信的、强大且成功的职场女强人。所有这些人，还有你，在通往成功的旅程中以及在他们最终到达的终点上，都有一个非常重要的共同点：那就是在某些时刻，他们完全不知道接下来会发生什么，他们只能孤注一掷，相信自己有这个能力。而一旦你开始寻找这些故事，你就会到处看到它们。你会不断地看到它们，直到有一天，你也会拥有属于你自己的这类故事，关于你如何克服不确定性，关于在
hindsight the path was actually so clear the entire time. Another small thing you can do, and it's going to sound so minuscule and silly, you might be tempted to skip it. Please don't. I want you to make a playlist that you feel represents yourself and play it whenever you feel uncomfortable or confused as a way to really just bring yourself back and center yourself. Even if it doesn't necessarily help you feel less uncertain, it can just help you with the general feelings of discomfort and strangeness that you may be having. having and just is like a fun thing to do, a fun thing to do to remind yourself of who you are,
事后看来其实一目了然的整条道路。你可以做的另一个小事——听起来可能微不足道且有点傻，你可能会想跳过它。请千万不要。我希望你能制作一个你觉得能代表你自己的播放列表，每当你感到不舒服或困惑时就播放它，以此来真正让自己平静并找回自我。即使它不一定能帮你不那么感到不确定，它也能帮你缓解你可能正在经历的不适感和陌生感，这只是一件有趣的事，一件能提醒你你是谁的趣事，
of who you want to be, of what your core values are, all through music. These songs reflect how you see yourself back at you. And that is a very special, familiar, beautiful feeling. There's actually this brilliant 2014 paper from a researcher in Texas that talks about how music contributes to the formation of our identity and can help us trust our more because it acts as a touchstone when we feel challenged. It represents all the times we have previously overcome challenges, all the times we previously experienced joy. And the music we choose really does reflect our values and says something about how we see ourselves. And so when you're kind
提醒你想成为谁，你的核心价值观是什么，这一切都通过音乐来实现。这些歌曲将你眼中的自己反射给你。那是一种非常特别、熟悉、美好的感觉。事实上，德克萨斯州的一位研究人员在2014年发表了一篇精彩的论文，谈到音乐如何促进我们身份的形成，并能帮助我们更多地信任自己，因为当我们感到受到挑战时，它就像是一个试金石。它代表了我们以前克服挑战的所有时刻，我们以前经历快乐的所有时刻。我们选择的音乐确实反映了我们的价值观，并说明了我们如何看待自己。因此，当你有点
of externally lost and don't really know who you are and can't really find your way back, music is just like beautiful anchor. You know, I have a playlist like this. The playlist is called If Gemma was a playlist. And I was listening to it literally the other day and it has songs from 2016 all the way up to last week. And it's really a beautiful way to see how I have transformed to be able to categorically see different chapters in my life and what was happening during them. And the music brings back all those memories and also just to see how far I've come. And so it's something you can literally take five minutes, do a few.
从外部感到迷失、真的不知道自己是谁、且无法找到回家的路时，音乐就像是一个美丽的锚。你知道的，我有一个这样的播放列表。这个播放列表叫做“如果杰玛是一个播放列表”。我前几天还在听它，里面有从2016年一直到上周的歌曲。这真的是一种美好的方式，让我看到自己是如何蜕变的，能够明确地看到我生活中的不同章节以及期间发生了什么。音乐带回了所有的记忆，也让我看到自己已经走了多远。所以你可以花上整整五分钟，做一点
yourself right now. It's a fun exercise. I promise you it will help you ground yourself during this like crazy chaotic period. On a much larger scale, the biggest antidote for uncertainty is really just this. Just try something. Try anything. Choose something that interests you to get good at. And when that thing stops serving you, choose something else. We have to let go of this idea. that every decision you make in life has to naturally flow into the next and the next and the next and that you have to have some step by step plan that you can follow for your life. Your life is not a recipe. You're not making a cake. You're not cooking sour. It's a series of experiments that take you to different places that you didn't even know you were going to
你现在就可以为自己做的事。这是一个有趣的练习。我向你保证，这会帮助你在这样一个疯狂混乱的时期脚踏实地。从更大的层面来看，应对不确定性的最大解药其实就是这个：去尝试一些事情。尝试任何事。选择一件你感兴趣的事情并把它做好。当那件事不再适合你时，选择另一件事。我们必须抛弃这种想法：
get to. And when you give yourself permission to just try, you really break this cycle of needing to know. You break this cycle of needing to have all the answers. And you move as well from that rumination spiral of, am I doing the right thing? Is this the best choice to just knowing that if you're taking action and if you're doing something, you are making the right choice. Even in perfect action, even the wrong choice is still a better choice than not doing anything at all. And it also gives you data. It gives you experience. It gives you stories. It gives you story. a question to really ask yourself as well if you're kind of thinking, okay, that's great, but which direction should I choose, especially if you're someone who has a lot of hobbies and interests
你在生活中做出的每一个决定都必须自然地衔接下一个、再下一个，你必须为自己的人生制定某种可以遵循的步步为营的计划。你的人生不是一本食谱。你不是在做蛋糕。你不是在做酸橘汁腌鱼。它是一系列把你带到你甚至不知道自己会到达的
and passions and ambitions? The question to ask yourself is just, what would make me most disappointed if I didn't do this? What would I be most regretful around not doing in 20 years' time? this mentally makes you kind of compute how much you have to lose by not acting rather than getting you stuck in this spiral of how much you have to lose by acting. It reminds me of this quote, you could take a million detours to your destination and still get there faster than someone who never got in the car. And that's the idea I really want to leave you with today.
不同地方的实验。当你允许自己去尝试时，你真正打破了“必须知道一切”的循环。你打破了“必须拥有所有答案”的循环。你也从“我做得对吗？这是最好的选择吗？”的纠结反刍漩涡中走出来，转变为这样一种认知：如果你正在采取行动，如果你正在做某事，你就是在做正确的选择。即使是不完美的行动，即使是错误的选择，也比什么都不做要好。它还能为你提供数据。它为你提供经验。它为你提供故事。它为你提供故事。这是一个真正需要问自己的问题，如果你在想，“好吧，这很好，但我应该选择哪个方向？”，特别是如果你是一个有很多爱好、兴趣、
Uncertainty in our 20s is inevitable, but it's actually a really profound sign that you're expanding and you are growing and you are reaching new spaces you haven't yet experienced. That's a good thing. Like congratulations. If you're feeling uncertain, that is such a beautiful sign and I wish I could give you all the applause for just trying and pushing yourself into new places and spaces. I know it feels uncomfortable, but I promise you that this discomfort has a purpose that you cannot yet see, lean into it, assign it a purpose while you're waiting, and just act, do anything, even if it's small things.
雄心壮志的人的话。你需要问自己的问题仅仅是：如果我不这样做，什么会让我感到最失望？20年後，我对什么没有去做会感到最遗憾？这种心态能让你权衡“不采取行动会失去多少”，而不是让你陷入“采取行动会失去多少”的思维漩涡。这让我想起了一句名言：你可以为了到达目的地而绕行一百万次，但仍然比那个从未上车的人更快到达。这就是我今天真正想留给你们的想法。
I think that that's a great solution for avoiding a worse discomfort of looking back of your life and realizing that you never did anything because you were scared of the unknown when the unknown is something that we always have to exist side by side with. and the only way to escape the unknown is to create a known, is to create a reality that you do really enjoy and that works for you. And the other way you can do that is through action. So that's a rather simple message, but also deeply complex message if you think about it to end
我们二十岁时的不确定性是不可避免的，但它实际上是一个非常深刻的信号，表明你正在扩张，你正在成长，你正在进入你尚未体验过的新空间。这是一件好事。就像恭喜你一样。如果你感到不确定，那真是一个美好的信号，我真想为你尝试并将自己推向新的地点和空间致以所有的掌声。我知道这感觉很不舒服，但我向你保证，这种不舒服是有它尚未显现的意义的，去顺应它，在等待的同时为它赋予一个目的，然后去行动，去做任何事，哪怕是很小的事情。
the episode with. I just hope that it brings you a sense of comfort that you're not the only one going through it. And then I totally know it's going to work out for you. It's totally going to work out for you. I know that. I can give you that promise right now. So thank you so much for listening. If you have made it this far. Let's leave a little emoji in the comments below that represents how you're feeling about your life, how uncertainty feels in your body right now. Just so I know if you've made it this far, if you're one of the loyal listeners, make sure that you are following along or subscribed wherever you are listening on YouTube, on Spotify, Apple, whatever one, and give us a five-star review. If you feel called to do so, it really does help the show grow and reach new audiences,
我认为这是一个极好的解决方案，可以避免一种更糟糕的不舒服感——那就是回首自己的人生，意识到自己因为害怕未知而从未做过任何事，而未知是我们必须永远与之共存的东西，
a new, fantastic, wonderful, 20-somethings and older. Also, make sure you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to be part of future episodes, if you want to DM me, episode suggestions, if you have questions, dilemmas, you may even be able to be featured in an episode just like this one. So follow me over there. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, especially in the face of uncertainty. We will talk very, very soon. 2%.
逃避未知的唯一方法就是创造一个已知，创造一个你真正喜欢且适合你的现实。而你做到这一点的另一种方式就是通过行动。所以这是一个相当简单的信息，但如果你仔细想想，这也是一个极其复杂的信息，作为本集的结尾。我只希望它能带给你一种安慰，让你知道并不是只有你一个人在经历这一切。并且我完全相信一切都会对你大有益处的。一切都一定会对你好的。我知道这一点。我现在就可以向你做出这个承诺。非常感谢你的收听。如果你听到了这里，让我们在下方的评论区留下一个小表情，代表你对生活的感受，代表你此刻身体里对不确定性的感觉。只是为了让我知道你是否听到了这里，如果你是忠实听众之一，请确保你在你收听的任何平台上关注或订阅了我们，无论是在YouTube、Spotify、Apple还是其他任何平台，并给我们一个五星好评。如果你愿意的话，这真的对节目的成长和触及新的受众——
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
那些年轻、精彩、美妙的二十几岁及以上的听众——有很大帮助。另外，请确保在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想参与未来的节目，如果你想给我发私信提出节目建议、如果你有疑问、困惑，你甚至可能有机会出现在像这样的一期节目中。所以去那边关注我吧。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，尤其是在面对不确定性的时候。我们很快就会再聊。2%。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的秘诀。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，在 I-Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为国会。快克。我随时都可以聊聊当年的快克，但为了让大家知道我的意思……我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上了桌面。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师Kear Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要吗？是因为你害怕才做一个好人吗？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。确实如此。这也是两种不同的信任级别。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我和Kear Gaines，
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini.
我们将深入探讨疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标等真实话题，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索Learn the Hard Way并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona.
暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律诉讼序幕，只为证明真相。你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下姑娘。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是Anna Sinfield。在这个新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女人发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。
and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you can, get your podcast. In 2003, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你可以获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2003年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Margini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《love trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《love trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. On the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我剖析了心理韧性、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女人发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他不会就这么逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝，在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。